see the UH Ben Affleck one yes with Sam
Harris yes
Sam's friend will love Sam I love Sam -
that was hilarious I think Ben I think
Ben Affleck was roided-up oh right I
really had that energy well he also was
like kind of red and thick
yeah his neck was thick like listen when
you're 40 whatever the [ __ ] age he is
and you want to pack on that kind of
muscles there's only one way you gotta
[ __ ] take that plunger up baby I hope
shoot yeah okay I think I think he was
juiced up and I think he just was hyper
aggressive virtue signaling and really
didn't even know what the [ __ ] he was
talking about and clearly picked the
wrong guy oh my god I would never argue
with Sam Harris I think about it I think
like the fact that he can't be President
really pisses me off like why can't I
want a guy who's smarter than me well he
could be President for sure being an
atheist hmm
maybe not yeah it's like why do I get I
don't get this whole thing of like I
want I want to vote for this guy I can
relate to him he's like me I don't want
a guy like me right it's like wanting a
babysitter like I want a baby sir I
wanted someone who's superior exactly
smarter I mean he's very meditative Sam
and mom and I firmly believe no one
should be President I think there should
be a counsel oh wise people I love that
idea
yeah like the Jedi Council [ __ ] eight
people or something just really really
smart people that have you know have and
I think they should all have had to do
mushrooms all of them Wow about that all
have to do psychedelic experiences
although they should be high cannot not
do mushrooms while they're on the job
but have in the past where the
understand there's there's more to life
than this thing that's part of the
platform the person needs to be like I
did try mushrooms didn't they stop oh no
you got it all you gotta go deep you
gotta take the heroic dose okay yeah
yeah I love that idea little think-tank
yeah eight people super wise people I
don't really think the mushroom thing is
necessary but but consider it wise
objective people that care and have a
the deep sense of responsibility to sort
of guide our country in the best way
possible I plan for their own interests
exactly I put Neil deGrasse Tyson on
this he'll be great
well he'll be great for some sort of a
role as a science educator in the
government anyway so some will see
what's great about Neil is he's one of
the first guys in our lifetime that made
science fun mmm made made astrophysics
interesting he's so enthusiastic yeah
he's a great guy I [ __ ] love he said
it if we have if aliens like we've got
to send one guy oh he's a guy Neil
deGrasse Tyson well he's also even even
though like he'll be talking to someone
who is you know just doesn't really
understand what he's saying he's not an
elitist exactly yeah he the way he
argues he's caring about him he's a
master at it he's a really likable guy
but he is like that all the time like
he's like that when the cameras off he's
just a great guy
and one quality has it rarely does
someone who's like really smart have is
he's a big laugher yeah yeah yeah yeah
like no he's a human fun guy you know he
used to be a wrestler time at mushrooms
huh he used to be a wrestler really yeah
I wrestled in high school he wasn't like
that yes I think he wrestled in college
too he was jacked like [ __ ] jacked
yeah he's an all-around quality human
yes Sam Harris - the way he argues just
stays calm mm-hmm well he doesn't argue
about things he doesn't understand
either mm-hmm you know like if Sam has a
conversation and say like he's having a
conversation with someone about whatever
the [ __ ] it is some some discipline
that's outside of his realm yeah and
then you know he'll ask questions like
he doesn't he's not it's not know-it-all
that they learn yeah go forget but if
he's talking to you about something and
he's arguing it's because he understands
what he's talking about that's that's a
rare quality man there's so many people
that want to argue about [ __ ] that they
really don't even understand you know
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with discussing things you really don't
understand to try to understand them
especially if you're doing it and
casual conversation or even a podcast
but there's a lot of [ __ ] people that
argue [ __ ] and they're just trying to
win you know they're just trying to
score polls yeah they're not really
talking right you get a lot of that
right I'd do it a lot but I'm more aware
of it watching people who don't do it
you learned it's a normal thing you get
caught up in your idea and then you want
your idea to be right yeah and then you
kind of like chase down all the evidence
that would show that your idea is right
you see this all the time when someone
gets accused of something and we don't
know exactly what happened you see these
groups of people that automatically want
to think that person is guilty and
automatic we have a preconceived idea of
what went down how it went down
regardless of what the other person said
like they only want to look at it one
way it just gets weird real weird with
people all right now do all the
information you have to be you have to
be a little more you know what hashtag
fake news hashtag hashtag I'll come back
I'll get smarter and come back
what kind of smart you're gonna get book
smarter and it gets Sam Harris Neil
deGrasse Tyson smart